[Music]
i know you have written about
in some respects inheriting the grief
or griefs of our parents and ancestors
could you speak to that
and
also mention if there's anything to be
done right or is it just like having
you know genetics for
like small calves and you're like well i
mean i go to the gym but they're always
going to be pretty small
or is there something that we can do
with whatever we have
accumulated through our bloodline
i
went down this whole path of looking at
inherited grief and i ended up devoting
a whole chapter of the book to it
because
originally it was just because i went to
this seminar for bereavement counselors
because i was just curious to learn more
about that
and what i found was
we were each asked to tell a story of
loss that we had experienced i really
didn't want to tell my story because i
felt like it wasn't as bad as some of
the other stories that i i heard that
day and i felt
wrong to be talking about it but i felt
like i had to because it seemed
ungenerous you know not to tell my story
and then when i did i found myself
crying much more than anybody else had
and
and the seminar was run by this
incredibly skillful guy named simra
raphael it was at the new york open
center
and
i forget how he came to it but he
basically said to me
that i seem to be
carrying a grief that was like apart
from what i personally had experienced
that i i was carrying a deeper grief
than that
and that it was a kind of grief of the
ancestors and
and i started realizing that
well i mean i i come from this family
that's kind of
mired in loss really
you know on both sides of my mother's
side and my father's side we lost almost
all of our relatives in the holocaust
and although those weren't people who i
knew directly there's kind of a shock
wave that
reverberates through
when he said that i realized that
i had always had this kind of tendency
to
even when i was a kid to cry at any kind
of moment where it was like
that which once was will never be again
even though at that point i had not
really experienced any loss in my life
and i had a happy life i still had this
intense reaction
and once he opened up that idea i
started
researching the whole
area of inherited grief it's like
it's absolutely fascinating you know
like there's all this research that
finds that
that the children of holocaust survivors
have particular
biomarkers
that you wouldn't find in another
control group population
and you can find this in animals too
it's a pretty it's a pretty new
area of research but the results are
incredibly compelling
there seems to be this
this idea this thing that we can
inherit from the people that came before
us and you know in a way the question of
whether it comes to us biologically or
because of what we learn from our
parents culturally it almost doesn't
matter we're inheriting it somehow
and then to your question of what can
you do about it
i have found it incredibly empowering to
know this because
there's a way in which you can get to
the inside of i'm gonna love those
ancestors and i'm gonna feel
empathy for that which they
experienced at the same time that you're
holding the idea that their story is not
my story
and i don't think we
take the time to realize that you can do
you can hold both those truths at the
same time their story is not my story
and yet i love them these people i've
never met before
i guess because music has been our theme
here there's this amazing song also by
dara williams it's called after all
and she it it's a masterpiece of a song
and it describes how she had been beset
by a kind of mysterious depression and
to come out of it she traveled down what
she calls the whispering well
of talking to her parents about
her family history and realizing all the
different things that she was carrying
from the people who had come before her
and how that process of excavating all
of that and understanding it and loving
it that was what freed her and then she
comes out into a kind of like shining
light on the other side and it it helps
her with her depression so you know
whether we're doing that through some
kind of formal therapy or through
our own sort of ad hoc process of
traveling down the whispering well there
are ways to do it
we don't have to take this
right turn because it could really
uncork pandora's box but
this is part of
one facet
of exploration in looking at psychedelic
assisted therapies
is
multi-generational
trauma or
ancestral grief
and
i also wanted to mention
lest anyone listening
think
who are these wackadoodles this sounds
like some new agey [ __ ]
i did a quick search just to pull it up
because i know it exists
here's an example and this is in
scientific american fearful memories
passed down to mouse descendants genetic
imprint from a traumatic experiences
carries through at least two generations
exactly and then this is from nature
magazine
which is also a very
respectable steam publication
and
there are in other words animal models
and
scientific studies and peer-reviewed
literature that supports this
in
various species of animal including mice
and the authors suggest a similar
phenomenon could influence anxiety and
addiction in humans
now there's a lot of skepticism i'm just
gonna i'm just gonna read a little bit
of this very quickly
some researchers are skeptical of
findings because a biological mechanism
that explains the phenomenon has has not
been identified i'm kind of skeptical of
such skeptics because
we all use for instance microwaves every
day but very few of us understand how
microwaves or refrigerators if you don't
like microwaves how they work right so
in the absence of a mechanism this is
also true for a lot of commonly
prescribed medications we still don't
actually understand how they work but
putting that aside so according to
convention this is going back to the
article the genetic sequences contained
in dna are the only way to transmit
biological information across
generations random dna mutations when
beneficial enable organizations to adapt
to changing conditions but this process
typically occurs slowly over many
generations
yet some studies have hinted that
environmental factors can influence
biology more rapidly through epigenetic
modifications which alter the expression
of genes
and it goes into
many more examples and so on but there
are a lot of scientists very credible
scientists including looks like
many quoted in this carrie wrestler
neurobiologist and psychiatrist at emory
university
who have studied this in
animals and i want to say someone could
call bs on this but i want to say that
it's even like this biological material
can sometimes be transferable from one
animal to another
even if they're not direct descendants
so if you use the electrical shocks
to
produce a state of acute anxiety and
learned helplessness in mice when you
turn off the lights that there is some
way of transferring
genetic material from that animal to an
unrelated but same species animal that
will induce
a similar
fear of the dark even though it has not
been learned so
there is in other words a biological
basis there seems to be a biological
basis for what exactly what you're
talking about right because the
holocaust in the grand scheme of things
is the example you used not that long
ago right really just not that long ago
so
i want to offer
two other ideas of ways to cope with
that yes please if you're listening and
you're thinking oh you know this
actually might speak to my experience
one is just kind of a simple reframing
that rachel yehuda who was the the
researcher who first discovered
this epigenetic tradition in holocaust
survivors
she talks about how
one of the people she who she worked
with
started to understand
this in herself and she started to
reframe when things would happen to her
like she'd have a bad day of work and
kind of overreact
she started saying oh well i now
understand that you know my shock
absorbers are a little thinner than
somebody else's might be and so i'm just
going to adjust around that and you know
this the simple knowledge and acceptance
is an incredible power
but to take it even a step further
beyond that
i talk to a lot of people who
are what you might call wounded healers
which is a kind of archetype
in the western tradition people who have
experienced some kind of wound or pain
and then
use that to try to heal the same pain
that they see other similarly situated
people
experiencing
and i talked for example i write about
this in the book with uh
the young woman who i called farah katib
she didn't want to use her real name
she's from the middle east and she felt
that
she didn't just feel she she came from a
family in which
all the generations of the women before
her
had
had suffered these horrible experiences
of rape and bereavement and all all
kinds of things
and um and she just found herself like
called
she she had some
job for a multinational company doing
marketing or something
and as part of that job
they had to do that thing you do where
you do lots of focus groups and listen
to people's stories and as she listened
to the stories of other women
there was something in those stories
that touched this nerve in her of all
the generations who had come before her
of women and her family and she found
herself leaving that job and flying back
to the middle east and starting to work
with women prisoners and then starting
her own not-for-profit to help women
refugees and there's something about
that work that she's doing to help heal
other people that is simultaneously
healing
herself
and with all of this i also want to say
at the same time it's not like
you know that's kind of a grand story
and when when we talk about creative
people who transform pain into beauty
you know they turn out to be leonard
cohn that sounds like really grand also
but you don't have to be doing these
things on such a grand scale it's just
like
you can be doing them on the most minute
level and you're still going through
that same mechanism of taking pain and
turning it into something else it's the
mechanism that matters
you